hi I'm here with Richard Fulcher
Richard is a UX designer at Google
senior UX designer that's right and has
been working on UX for the last 15 years
thank you for joining us Richard it's a
pleasure to be here today thanks for
having me to get started can you
describe what user experience design is
sure it's it's a big umbrella of several
related disciplines that are all focused
on the design of experiences to help a
individual person you know achieve some
kind of goal and that covers a lot of
different types of experiences most
commonly we think about software design
but it's also things like environment
design and maybe the design of physical
products it could even be things like
event coordination it's kind of anything
that a user experiences that can be
constructed for them when I was kind of
first taught this there was kind of five
key concepts it's the study of users and
their context can the environment they
operate in in order that we can design
tools for them to achieve tasks that let
them complete goals so users context
tasks and goals goals okay so let's
start with the user who are they well
the user is anyone who's going to use
the product or the service that you're
designing and it's really important to
remember that that runs a really wide
range you know it's very easy to kind of
when you're designing just think about
designing for yourself or this like one
super idealized user that you have in
mind
but in reality you're gonna be building
this for people with very different
levels of experience with different
contexts and different backgrounds that
affect how they'll perceive this thing
that you build for them all right and
how do I know who the user is
well the key for that is something
called user research I think it's kind
of most associated with this idea of
taking this product you're working on
and and testing it in some way you know
having a user come in and try to perform
a series of tasks
that you assign them and see how they do
and see the things that are problems for
them but user research really covers the
whole end-to-end development of the
product even before you've drawn your
first screen you can engage with user
research to go into your potential users
homes or workplaces to start to
understand you know that context that's
important to the way that they behave
and what their goals are and once you've
even kind of finished and shipped you
can do things like look at logs and try
to analyze usage patterns see what
people are doing with your product
perhaps kind of bias towards things that
you want them to do more of or see areas
that they're spending a lot of time in
that you haven't anticipated